armando barre suela ha vuelto de
realizar la labor de pesca más lejos de
lo habitual la prohibición de pesca a
30.000 km impuesta tras la creación de
la nueva zona marítima protegida en
galápagos ha cambiado su rutina de
trabajo y le genera inquietud también a
la ciencia porque engrasa más pesca más
más pesca de gracias a la reserva pero
no trata mal pero no la vayan a salir a
pescar
marius y que viven de la pesca de su
esposo del mercado del pueblo señala que
pescar más lejos supone invertir de 300
a mil 500 dólares en combustibles
entonces eso de la reserva marina es
bueno por una parte
ayuda pero por otra parte porque los
barcos de afuera de china todo eso aquí
al galapagueño le impiden el
producto de que hay aquí la reserva de
60 mil kilómetros recién declarada en
las islas ecuatorianas fue creada en pro
del ambiente en venta además de limitar
la pesca indiscriminada por parte de
flotas internacionales contribuir con la
preservación de las especies la
generación de oxígeno y ayudar con el
campo de la investigación
a través de la creación de la reserva
hermandad hacemos un llamado a todas las
naciones del mundo a unirse a este
esfuerzo colectivo
y a preservar lo bien reemplazado los
tesoros del océano otras opiniones de
pescadores varían de la de armando louis
apoyar el corredor marítimo y espera que
sea una mayor fuente abastecimiento y
reserva de biósfera del planeta
habría menos captura de peces por la
parte
extranjera ya que los ecuatorianos tanto
en la parte continental que también al
segundo de esa también tendrían derecho
de vuelta en el mercado armando aplaude
que se rescaten las especies con esta
nueva zona de protección sin embargo
espera que con el corredor marítimo la
pesca artesanal y los 1.100 pescadores
que hacen vida en galápagos también
queden protegidos